This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. February 23rd 2009, Christie's International in Paris held a much anticipated three-day auction from the private art collection of the late-fashioned designer, Eve Saint Laurent. The auction took place at the historic Grand Palais, and the items up for sale were 733 pieces that Sanderan and his partner, Pierre Berger, had amassed over five decades. The French press dubbed this the sale of the century. There was a piece by Marcel Duchamp, a painting from Picasso's Cubus period, even a landscape by Edgar de Gaude that had once hung at Pierre Berger's bedside.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。2009年2月23日，佳士得国际拍卖行在巴黎举办了一场备受瞩目的为期三天的拍卖会，拍品来自已故时装设计师伊夫·圣罗兰的私人艺术收藏。拍卖会在历史悠久的巴黎大皇宫举行，上拍的物品包括圣罗兰及其伴侣皮埃尔·贝尔热在五十年里积攒的733件藏品。法国媒体将这场拍卖誉为世纪大拍。其中有一件马塞尔·杜尚的作品，一幅来自毕加索立体主义时期的画作，甚至还有一幅埃德加·德加的风景画，这幅画曾经挂在皮埃尔·贝尔热的床头。
Interested buyers from all over the world flocked to the Champs-Ilysées for a piece of the action. It will be a great, great event, you know, an event the like of which we've never seen before, both in terms of people congregating to see the San Laurent collection, but also in terms of the prices that will be achieved. But probably the two most anticipated items at the event were a pair of bronze animal heads from China, one of a rabbit and one of a rat that dated back to the 18th century Qing dynasty. They're quite odd looking and I don't find them beautiful. This is Audrey Wang. She's a historian of Chinese art and was an Asian art specialist with Christie's auction house.
来自世界各地的买家蜂拥至香榭丽舍大街，想要分一杯羹。“这将是一场非常盛大的活动，你知道的，一场前所未见的活动，不仅体现在人们聚集一堂来参观圣罗兰的收藏，也体现在将要创下的价格纪录上。”但这场活动中最受期待的两件物品，可能是一对来自中国的青铜兽首，一个是兔首，一个是鼠首，可追溯到18世纪的清朝。它们看起来挺奇怪的，我并不觉得它们美。这是奥黛丽·王。她是一位中国艺术史学家，曾担任佳士得拍卖行的亚洲艺术专家。
Through my time, I had the opportunity to work with some pretty amazing art. On the third and final day of the auction, the bronze heads went up for sale one at a time, starting with the rat. The opening bits started at 9 million euros. It quickly rose to 10 million. Then it jumped to 13 million. Then someone bid 14 million euros by telephone. It sold to the unseen telephone buyer for 14 million euros.
在我任职期间，我有机会接触到一些非常惊艳的艺术品。在拍卖的第三天也是最后一天，青铜兽首被逐一拿出来拍卖，首先是鼠首。起拍价从900万欧元开始。迅速攀升至1000万。接着跃升至13万（应为1300万）欧元。然后有人通过电话出价1400万欧元。它以1400万欧元的价格卖给了一位神秘的电话买家。
The rabbit bronze followed its similar pattern. With the same unnamed bitter, winning the second bronze for the same price. After lots of bidding, I believe it was a Chinese collector caught timing Zhao, who eventually bought the heads, or rather was successful in bidding for the heads. Simon Chao was an art collector and dealer based in China, so it wasn't all that surprising that he was the winning bidder. But what was surprising was what happened
兔首铜像也遵循了类似的模式。由同一位未具名的出价者以相同的价格拍下了第二个青铜兽首。经过多次竞标，我相信是一位名叫蔡铭超的中国收藏家最终买下了兽首，或者更准确地说，成功竞得这些兽首。蔡铭超是一位常驻中国的艺术收藏家和经销商，所以他成为最终买家其实并不算太令人意外。但令人意外的是接下来发生的事情。
next. Having bid nearly $40 million at auction last week, We have stood up, and thankfully I was given this opportunity, which I felt was my responsibility. And what I want to stress is I will not pay for this bid. He refused to pay the tab as an act of protest. It was a statement. He was making a statement. As it turns out, the rabbit and rat bronzes weren't just decorative works of art meant to sit under a dusty glass case in some private collection. The animal heads were looted from China during one of the worst incidents of cultural vandalism the country has ever seen. By stopping the sale, Sai was signaling to the world that China wanted its stuff back. These bronze heads are at the center of a big fight over the repatriation of Chinese
上周在拍卖会上出价近4000万美元后，我站了出来，幸运的是我得到了这个机会，我觉得这是我的责任。我想强调的是，我不会为这次出价付款。他拒绝支付这笔账单，以此作为抗议行动。这是一个表态。他在表明立场。事实证明，兔首和鼠首铜像不仅仅是放在某些私人收藏中蒙尘玻璃柜下的装饰性艺术品。这些兽首是中国在经历该国历史上最严重的文化破坏事件之一时被掠夺走的。萨伊通过叫停这场拍卖，向世界发出信号：中国想要回属于自己的东西。这些青铜兽首是一场关于中国文化遗产追索权的大规模争端的核心，但这并不是因为它们的艺术价值。而是因为它们背后的故事，以及这个故事对中国政府意味着什么。在这场让全球拍卖行天翻地覆的兽首现身之前，它们曾是一个喷泉的一部分。所以如果我们想象自己走进这个花园，你实际上看到的不仅是兽首，还有这些围绕喷泉坐落的雕塑。这是帕特里夏·于。她在加州大学伯克利分校研究艺术史。你会看到穿着人类衣服的雕塑，但它们的头部是十二生肖动物的头。
cultural heritage, but it's not because of their artistic value. It's because of the story behind them, and what that story means to the government of China. Before the animal heads were upending auction houses around the world, they were pieces of a fountain. So if we were to imagine ourselves walking into this garden, you would actually see not just heads, but these sculptures that are seated around a fountain. This is Patricia Yu. She studies the history of art at UC Berkeley. And you would be seeing sculptures with human closed bodies, but then the head would be the head of a
这个喷泉有点像一个会动的喷泉水钟，以中国十二生肖的十二种动物为特色。温故知新一下，十二生肖是鼠、牛、虎、兔、龙、蛇、马、羊、猴、鸡、狗和猪。每一个农历年都由不同的动物代表，所以你可以像我一样出生于虎年。或者像我一样出生在无可争议更酷的龙年。这些青铜喷泉兽首每天会在一天中的两个小时里，从不同动物的口中喷出水来，以象征时间的流逝。
zodiac animal. The fountain was sort of like an animated water clock, which featured the 12 animals of the Chinese zodiac. Just as a refresher, the 12 animals of the zodiac are the rat, ox, tiger, rabbit, dragon, snake, horse, goat, monkey, rooster, dog, and the boar. Every lunar year is represented by a different animal, so you can be born in the year of the tiger, like me. Or the inarguably cooler year of the dragon, like me. The bronze fountain heads would spout water out of a different animal's mouth for two hours a day every day to signify the passing of time.
这个动物喷泉是欧洲与中国风格相结合的设计，由意大利耶稣会士为圆明园（一个规模大得多且极其奢华的中国皇家宫殿群）内的一个欧洲主题花园而建造。圆明园的英文直译是“完美明亮的花园”（Garden of Perfect Brightness）。圆明园是一个巨大的园林建筑群，最早于1700年代为清朝皇帝的皇室成员建造。这是他远离紫禁城主要住所的另一个家。
The animal fountain was a hybrid European and Chinese design, built by Italian Jesuits for a European-themed garden within a much larger and much more extravagant Chinese palace complex called Yuan Ming Yuan. The translation of Yuan Ming Yuan is the Garden of Perfect Brightness. The Yuan Min Yuan was an immense garden complex, first constructed in the 1700s for the Imperial family of the Emperor of the Qing Dynasty. It was his home away from home
也就是说，这是一个拥有中央公园大小、由数百个亭台楼阁组成、挤满了各种壮观艺术与建筑的度假行宫。这个地方非常巨大，它实际上收藏了清朝皇家文物和艺术品中非常、非常大的一部分，以及皇室最精美的珍宝。这是弗雷德里克·格林，旧金山州立大学中国文学教授。他说，圆明园或许象征着帝国的辉煌，但它的历史将由悲剧来定义。
from his primary residence at the Forbidden City. That is, a home away from home that was a size of central park made up of hundreds of pavilions and was packed with all sorts of spectacular art and architecture. This place was huge and it actually held a very, very large part of the imperial collection of antiquities and artworks and some of the finest treasures of the imperial family. This is Frederick Green, professor of Chinese literature at San Francisco State University. He says that the Yuan Ming Yuan may have symbolized Imperial Granger,
所以这一切确实始于第一次鸦片战争（1839年），接着是第二次鸦片战争。当然，这些战争也是可怕的战争，因为它们的动机在某种程度上至少是由英国人随后强加给中国的一种毒品引起的。在1860年第二次鸦片战争接近尾声时，清朝官员扣押了英法外交代表团。因此西方军队通过向圆明园推进作出回应。
but its story would be defined by tragedy. So it starts really with the first Opium War, 1839, followed by a second Opium War. And these wars, of course, were also terrible wars in that they were motivated by, to some degree, at least by a drug that the British then forced upon the Chinese. Towards the end of the second opium war in 1860, Ching officials captured a British and French delegation. So Western forces responded by advancing
但当士兵们抵达这座庞大的皇家园林时，他们意识到皇帝拥有如此多的精美物品。随后爆发了一场疯狂的劫掠。他们花了数天时间抢夺所有有价值的东西，黄金、瓷器、玉器、手表、景泰蓝，而且他们带着一种狂欢和喜悦的情绪。几乎就像《人类清除计划》里的场景。我不敢用“令人愉悦”这个词，因为我觉得在劫掠的背景下我们不该用这个词，但从他们的视角来看，这几乎是一种对夺取和毁灭身边罕见异国物品的纯粹纵容的嘉年华氛围。
towards the UN Ming-U-N. But when the soldiers arrived at this vast garden palace, they realized just how many pretty things the Emperor had. And a frenzy of looting happened. They spent days grabbing everything of value, gold, porcelains, jades, watches, enams, and they did it with a kind of balkanali and glee. Almost like a scene from the purge. I hesitate to use the word delightful, because I feel like we shouldn't use that in the context of looting, but from their perspective, this almost carnival atmosphere of sheer indulgence in the taking possession of and destruction of the rare and exotic items around them.
然而他们带不走的东西，全被毁掉了。他们砸碎了花瓶和镜子。甚至还有记载称，士兵们用图书馆里的珍贵手稿来点烟。最糟糕的是，劫掠不仅局限于无生命的物品。他们还特意挑选了一些东西作为礼物送给英国维多利亚女王，以及法国的欧仁妮皇后。
But whatever they couldn't carry, they destroyed. They smashed vases and mirrors. There are even accounts of soldiers using rare manuscripts from the library to light their pipes. And the worst part was that the looting wasn't even confined to inanimate objects. They also set a certain things specifically to give as gifts to Queen Victoria, as well as to Empress Eugini in France.
所以维多利亚女王得到了这只名叫露迪（Loody）的小北京犬。Loody就像looted（被掠夺的）那个词。如果这还不够让人恶心的话，英国军队当时还由埃尔金勋爵的儿子率领，就是那个从希腊偷走帕台农神庙大理石雕的人。在掠夺不属于自己的东西这件事上，这多少有点家族传承的意思。你知道，据某些估计，当时那里大约有150万件藏品。而且，所有这些都被洗劫一空。一旦所有有价值的东西都被拿走，
So Queen Victoria got this little pecanese dog that was named loody. Loody as in loody. And just in case that's not icky enough, the British forces were also led by the son of Lord Elgin, the guy who stole the Parthenon marbles from Greece. There's a little bit of a family affair in the taking of things that don't belong to. You know, by some estimates, you know, maybe 1.5 million pieces were there. And, you know, all of that was taken. Once everything of value was taken,
士兵们便放火烧了圆明园。这个建筑群太大了，足足烧了三天三夜。讽刺的是，这座辉煌的中国宫殿中幸存下来的少数建筑之一，是青铜十二生肖曾经矗立的欧洲景区石 фаса（立面），那是对西方建筑顶礼膜拜的巴洛克残迹。
the soldiers set fire to the UN, Ming-Uen. The complex was so large, it took three full days to burn down. Ironically, one of the few structures that survived from this resplendent Chinese palace was the stone facade of the European section where the bronze zodiacs once stood, baroque remnants of an homage to Western architecture.
在劫掠过程中的某个时刻，青铜兽首被从它们的身体上硬生生地扯了下来，但当时它们只是那150万件物品中的区区12件。没有人给予它们任何特殊的关注，它们在混乱中失踪了，据推测可能永远丢失了。直到20世纪80年代。我相信那是在1987年的夏天。这是拉马克森。他是中国艺术品专家兼美国鉴定师协会会长。你可能也在一个我心目中堪称美国机构的电视节目中认出他。我从1996年第一季开始就一直出演《古董路演》（Antiques Roadshow）。但在那之前，他曾在苏富比工作。
Sometime during the looting, the bronze heads were torn from their bodies, but at that point they were just 12 of those 1.5 million pieces. No one paid them any special attention and they went missing in the chaos Presumably lost forever. That is until the 1980s. I believe it was in the summer of 1987. This is Lark Mason He's a specialist in Chinese works of art and president of the appraisers association of America You might also recognize him from a television show that is in my opinion an American institution. I have appeared on Antiques Road shows since 1996 since the very first season. But before that, he worked for Sotheby's.
在1987年，他接到了一位夫妇打来的非常有趣的电话，他们想对一对古董进行估价。他们把东西带到了我们的画廊，我看着他们打开这些东西并摆在我面前，心想，哦天哪，这些太棒了，但它们是什么？它们是12个青铜兽首中的两个，猴首和猪首。马森从工艺上看出这些是非常精美的藏品，但他对这些兽首一无所知。当时，没有人知道。在我看到它们的那个时期，从广义上讲，人们肯定没有认出这些是什么。
And in 1987, he received a very interesting phone call from a couple looking to have a pair of antiquities valued. They brought them into our gallery and I watched them as they opened these up and put them before me and thought, oh my gosh, these are wonderful, but what are they? They were two of the 12 bronze animal heads, the monkey and the boar. Mason could tell from the craftsmanship that these were very fine pieces, but he didn't know anything about the heads. At the time, no one did. At the time I saw them, there was certainly no recognition of what these were in a broad
它们非常鲜为人知。它们背后的整个概念也是鲜为人知的。青铜器的所有者相信它们可能来自圆明园。因此，在研究这座皇家园林的过程中，马森偶然发现了一些可以追溯到18世纪的版画。它们相当于由新房子的自豪业主拍摄或刊登在建筑文摘上的照片。而在这些建筑版画中，正是有着青铜十二生肖兽首点缀的喷泉。马森实际上是最早弄清楚这些兽首是从喷泉上被拆卸下来的人之一。据我所知，当我看到头两个的时候，我甚至不知道一共有12个。
sense. They were very obscure. The whole idea behind them was obscure. The owners of the bronze's believed that they'd probably come from the UN Ming-U-N. So in the process of researching the palace complex, Mason came across some engravings that dated back to the 18th century. They were the equivalent of photographs
我当时只看到了这两个动物头。马森了解圆明园的历史，但这些所有者在技术上是合法购买这些兽首的，而且这种类型的交易在艺术品市场上相当正常。如果要说有什么不同的话，那就是能够建立证明其皇家出处的所有权链让它们变得更有价值。当这些兽首被拿去拍卖时，马森估计这些青铜器可能价值6万到8万美元不等，但拍卖结果比他预期的还要好。出人意料的是，猴首拍出了15万美元的高价。
that are taken by a proud owner of a new house or spread an architectural digest. And in these architectural engravings were the bronze zodiac heads ornamenting a fountain. Mason was actually one of the first people to figure out that the heads had been disassembled from the fountain. As far as I know at the time when I saw the first two, I did not know they were 12, even.
而猪首则拍得9.5万美元。在那之后，其他青铜兽首开始慢慢在艺术品市场上崭露头角。下一个出现的是1989年的牛首、虎首和马首，到那时，这些青铜器的知名度已经显著提升。你知道，每个兽首的价格都在三十、四十、五十万美元的范围内。接着在2000年，三个青铜兽首被拿出来拍卖。虎首由苏富比拍卖行出售，而牛首和猴首则由佳士得经手。我们将这次拍卖命名为“圆明园”，而这差不多就是所有麻烦开始的地方。
I just saw these two animal heads. Mason was aware of the history of the UN Ming Yuan, but the owners had technically purchased the heads legally, and this type of sale was pretty normal in the art market. If anything, being able to establish a chain of custody that proved their imperial provenance made them more valuable. When the heads went up for auction, Mason estimated the bronzes might be worth anywhere from 60 to 80 thousand dollars, But the sale went even better than he expected. The monkey head, surprisingly enough, made $150,000.
这是奥黛丽·王，也就是曾在佳士得工作过的艺术品专家。当时，她正在协助安排牛首和猴首的拍卖，她本以为这次拍卖会像往常一样正常进行。我们一直都有宫廷藏品拍卖。我们只是在做同样的事情。但这次拍卖的进展与这些青铜器上一次被拿出来拍卖时大不相同。当然，佳士得和苏富比只是在做他们一直在做的事情，出售珍贵的古董。
And for the boar head, it was $95,000. After that, other bronze heads began slowly popping up in the art market. The next to appear were the ox tiger and horse in 1989 and by then the profile of the bronzes had only grown. You know it was in the three four five hundred thousand range for each head. And then in the year 2000 three bronzes heads went up for sale. The tiger head was being sold by Sotheby's while the ox and monkey were handled by Christie's. We gave this auction the code name Yuan-Ning Yuan, and that was kind of where all the troubles started.
但他们没有意识到的是，围绕这些青铜器的舆论情绪已经发生了转变。王女士说，在拍卖当天，她迎面遇到了一群试图阻止拍卖这些兽首的抗议者。面对愤怒的人群，我感到十分震惊。她透露，为了把抗议者挡在外面，拍卖举办的酒店拉下了金属卷帘门，阻止任何人进入大楼。正当金属卷帘门缓缓落下时，主要的抗议者，呃，他像印第安纳·琼斯一样从卷帘门下滑了进去，成功闯了进去，并高喊拍卖行是
This is Audrey Wang again, the art specialist who had worked at Christie's. At the time, she was helping to arrange the sale of the Ox and the Monkey heads, and she expected the sale to be business as usual. We've always had an imperial sale. We were just doing the same thing. But this sale went very differently than the last time the bronzes went up for auction. Sure, Christie's and Sotheby's were just doing what they'd always done, selling valuable antiquities.
叛徒，兽首属于中国。这些抗议者认为，这些兽首不仅仅是可以拍卖给最高出价者的艺术品。它们是应当归还中国的文化遗产。在整个20世纪70和80年代，关于保护文化遗产的讨论在世界各地日益增多。但到了2000年代，这些讨论开始针对佳士得和苏富比这样的拍卖行，尤其是当涉及保护中国文化遗产的时候。
But what they didn't realize was that the sentiment around the bronzes had shifted. Wang says that on the day of the auction, she was met with a sea of protesters trying to block the sale of the heads. And I was shocked to be confronted with an angry mob. She sent that in order to keep protesters out, the hotel where the auction was being held, pulled down metal shutters to block anyone from entering the building. And as the metal shutters were coming down, the main protester, uh, he did an Indiana Jones style role under the shutters and managed to make it in shouting the auction houses were
那正是所有关于文物返还的讨论刚刚兴起的时候。所以，即使把它们拿出来拍卖可能是合法的，但宣传某个中国古董来自圆明园，本质上就是在宣传它是从宫殿里巧取豪夺来的，字面意思上，那个地方的所有东西都是被掠夺的。你无法洗白它们流转的历史。还是帕特里夏·于。我们确切地知道什么被毁了。我们确切地知道这一切是何时发生的。
the traitors and that the heads belonged China. These protesters believed that the heads were more than just pieces of art that could be auctioned off to the highest bidder. They were a cultural heritage that should be returned back to China. Throughout the 1970s and 80s, discussions about the protection of cultural heritage increased all over the world. But by the 2000s, these discussions became directed at auction houses like Christie's and Sotheby's, especially when it came to the protection of Chinese cultural heritage.
数以百万计的文物被非法从中国掠夺出去，但青铜兽首特别是文物返还努力中的一个巨大焦点。它们在某种程度上已经成为了文化财产回归的吉祥物。它们确实已经成为了，你知道的，国家象征。它们已经成为了爱国主义的象征。它们如此炙手可热的一个原因，是有有据可查的视觉证据表明这些兽首曾经矗立在圆明园。但围绕着环游世界前往不同的国际拍卖会场试图追踪这失踪的中国十二生肖的想法，也有一种迷人之处。是的，这其中有一种非常强烈的寻宝探险意味，
That was the very start of when all the talk about repatriation, you know, when it all started. So even though it might be legal to put it up for sale, advertising that a Chinese antiquity came from the UN Ming-U-N was essentially advertising that it was pilferred from the palace, literally everything from that place was looted. You can't whitewash the history of their movement. Patricia you again. We know exactly what was destroyed. We know exactly when it happened.
因为这是一套已知的藏品。对于十二生肖，每个人都知道有12个。每个人都知道它们的顺序。所以这意味着我们基本上确切地知道——谁还在失踪？寻找失踪的兽首是一个如此具有感召力的目标，以至于连成龙也参与其中。成龙，香港武术电影界传奇的武术演员，也是呼吁归还被掠夺中国文物的坚定支持者。女士们先生们，世界上仅存四个了。
Millions of antiquities have been illegally taken from China, but the Bronzeheads in particular have been a huge focal point in repatriation efforts. They've in a way become mascots for the return of cultural property. They really have become, you know, national symbols. They have become symbols of patriotism. One reason they're so sought after is that there's documented visual proof that these heads once stood at the UN Ming-Yuan. But there's also something captivating about the idea of traveling around the world to different international auction sites trying to track down the 12 missing animals of the Chinese zodiac. Yeah, there is something very quest-like about it
成龙甚至编剧、导演并主演了一部名为《十二生肖》的动作武术电影。他在片中饰演一个类似印第安纳·琼斯的探险寻宝人物。今天是充满印第安纳·琼斯梗的一天。在电影中，成龙饰演一名肩负寻找失落生肖任务的寻宝人。它实际上成为了中国内地票房最高的电影之一。我的意思是，坦率地说，作为一部电影，它本身并不算出色。但作为一个能看到成龙从飞机上跳下并降落在活火山上的载体，它确实不错。
because it's a known set. With the zodiac animals, everyone knows there's 12. Everyone knows the order. So what it means is we kind of know exactly like who's still missing? Finding the missing heads was such an evocative goal that even Jackie Chan got involved. Jackie Chan, very storied martial arts actor of the Hong Kong martial arts movie scene, has also been a quite vocal proponent of the repatriation of Looted Chinese artifacts. Ladies and gentlemen, there are only four in the world.
现实中，将青铜兽首和其他非法盗窃的财产归还中国，通常不需要牛鞭和皮夹克，只需要一个非常大的银行账户。2000年、2003年和2007年的所有拍卖，最终都是由与中国政府有关联的组织或是那些购买兽首
Chan even wrote, directed, and starred in a martial arts action film called Chinese Zodiac. He plays a kind of Indiana Jones-like, adventuring figure. This is a huge day for Indiana Jones references. In the film, Chan plays a treasure hunter tasked with finding the lost Zodiacs. It actually became one of the highest grossing domestic films in China. I mean, the movie itself is quite frankly not good as a movie. But it is good as a vehicle to see Jackie Chan jump out of an airplane and land on an active volcano.
然后将其捐赠回中国的亿万富翁买下了兽首。抗议和参与拍卖被掠夺的文物听起来可能有些矛盾，但有时绕过国际财产法繁文缛节的最简单方法，就是掏出你的钱包。我总觉得那就变成了，好吧，既然你们不愿通过合法渠道把它们归还。那么，我的钱包比你们的大。
In reality, repatriating the bronze heads and other illicitly stolen property back to China doesn't usually require a bullwhip and a leather jacket, just a really big bank account. All of the auctions in 2000, 2003, in 2007 ended with the heads being purchased either by groups affiliated with the Chinese government or by billionaires who purchased
每当这些青铜兽首现身拍卖行时，都会传递出一个非常清晰的信息。正是这种叙事，让抗议者在金属卷帘门下翻滚，或者启发成龙拍摄了关于它的宏大卖座电影。没有任何真正的伦理或道德理由去霸占明确被掠夺的物品。所以是的，我认为把它们归还可能是正确的事情。这确实是正确的事情。但正是在这里，寻找和归还青铜兽首这一高尚的行为开始变得
and then donated the heads back to China. It may sound a little contradictory to both protest and participate in the sale of looted artifacts, but sometimes the easiest way to get around the red tape of international property law is to whip out your pocketbook. I kind of feel like then it just becomes like, okay fine, if you won't just give them back through legal channels. Well, my wallet's bigger than yours.
模糊不清。因为就兽首而言，所谓的“正确之事”，可能会出于错误的理由而发生。它们是文化的一部分。它们是对文化的回应。但在不同的历史时期，它们在不同的方面被用于政治目的。有些人实际上对中国政府追索青铜兽首的努力提出了质疑。
There's a very clear message that the Bronzeheads communicate every time they show up at an auction house. It's the same narrative that has protesters rolling under metal shutter doors, or inspires Jackie Chan to make huge blockbuster movies about it. There's no real ethical or moral reason to hold on to known looted objects. So yes, I see like giving them back is probably the right thing to do. It is the right thing to do. But this is where the noble act of finding and returning the Bronze Heads starts to get
像艾未未这样的人。这是艾未未，我是一位艺术家，好吧，许多人并不这么认为，他们只是叫我艺术家。艾未未一直公开批评中国政府追索青铜兽首的任务。不仅如此，他甚至创作了自己的艺术品《十二生肖兽首圆阵》（Circle of Animals/Zodiac Heads），这是对青铜器的重新诠释。在艾未未看来，这些动物兽首根本算不上中国的文化遗物，特别是如果你考虑到这些青铜兽首实际上是由欧洲人设计的。
muddy. Because in the case of the Heads, the, quote, right thing to do can happen for the wrong reasons. They're part of culture. They are a response to culture. But they are used for political purposes in different ways at different periods of time. There are some people who have actually questioned the Chinese government's efforts to repatriate the Bronzeheads.
这场战争是由一位在圆明园工作的著名中国牧师（应为意大利传教士郎世宁，此处原文听译有误，即由欧洲人设计）。由欧洲人设计。但却把这选作中国的宝藏，这简直荒谬。如果你回到1987年，当时头两个青铜兽首刚崭露头角时，根本没有人寻找它们。事实上，当时的中国领导层根本没有纠结于圆明园的历史。在整个20世纪70和80年代，圆明园基本上是一个被忽视的遗址。像艾未未这样的艺术家接管了这个空间，甚至在欧洲花园被遗忘的废墟中生活和工作。他说，当地的养猪农户实际上把废墟的大理石当作他们房屋的建筑材料。
People like Ai Wei Wei. This is Ai Wei Wei, I'm an artist and well, no many, they just call me an artist. Ai Wei Wei has been openly critical of the Chinese government's mission to repatriate the Bronzeheads. So much so, that he even created his own art piece called Circle of Animals zodiac heads, which was a reinterpretation of the Bronze. To I, the animal heads aren't Chinese cultural relics at all, especially if you consider that the Bronzeheads were actually designed by Europeans.
当地的农民会把那些大理石块搬回去，砌进他们的房子地基里。所以你经常走来走去，会说，哦，这里有一块来自圆明园的碎片，因为根本没有人关心。但这一切在1989年之后发生了改变。在通往天安门广场主干道的街道上，愤怒的人们难以置信地瞥见……
The war has made by a famous Chinese priest who worked in Pearl Court. designed by Europeans. But that could choose that as a Chinese treasure with the ridiculous. If you go back to 1987, when the first two bronze heads appeared on the scene, no one was looking for them. In fact, Chinese leadership wasn't dwelling on the history of the UN Ming-Yuan at all. The UN Ming-Yuan was a mostly neglected site throughout the 1970s and 80s. Artists like Iwayway took over the space and actually lived and worked in the forgotten ruins of the European Garden. He says that pig farmers nearby would actually use the marble of the ruins as building material for their homes.
1989年，当然，你知道，天安门广场发生的这些事情，党内的一些人，一些党内元老当然把这些解读为对共产主义统治的挑战。为了回应天安门广场的事件，中国领导层觉得他们需要在年轻一代中恢复对共产党的忠诚。他们通过一项名为“爱国主义教育”的课程，重塑中国的历史记忆来实现这一点。爱国主义教育运动在1989年学生运动之后急剧展开，并与历史教科书的改变息息相关。这是汪江，西东厅大学（应为Seton Hall University，西东大学）外交与国际关系学院教授。
The local farmers would bring back those marble pieces, toucinates, their houses, foundations. So you often feel walk around, they can say, oh, here's a piece from your knee, because nobody cares. But that all changed after 1989. On the streets leading down to the main road to Tiananmen Square, furious people stared in disbelief at the glimpses.
爱国主义教育旨在激发民族自豪感和忠诚度。这门课程美化了共产党，并大肆渲染中国遭到外国列强剥削的经历。而爱国主义教育运动的核心就是“百年耻辱”。“百年耻辱”的概念在中国是一个特殊的叙事。因为在大约这100年里，中国遭受了大量的外国侵略并输掉了战争。因此，中国人认为这是他们历史上最黑暗的时期。
1989, of course, you know, these events at Tiananmen Square, some people in the party, some party elders interpreted these, of course, as a challenge to communist rule. In response to the events at Tiananmen Square, Chinese leadership felt that they needed to restore communist party loyalty in younger generations. They did this by reshaping China's historical memory through a curriculum called patriotic education. Patriotic education campaign started sharply after the student's movement in 1989 and is related with the change of the history textbooks. This is Jiang Wang, a professor at the School of Diplomacy and International Relations at Seton Hall University.
从1839年第一次鸦片战争开始，一直持续到1949年中华人民共和国成立，中国遭到外国势力的猛烈痛击。它经历了不平等条约、领土丧失和多次战争。由于发生了巨大的文化遗产损失，百年耻辱中的一个关键事件就是圆明园的劫掠。圆明园在某种程度上成为了国耻的象征，因此它被用作爱国主义教育的基地。其目标是确保年轻一代永远不会忘记中国历史上最低谷的时期，或者外国侵略者对中国文化的摧残。
Patriotic education was supposed to boost national pride and loyalty. The curriculum glorified the Communist Party and played up the ways that China had been exploited by foreign powers. And at the heart of the patriotic education campaign was the century of humiliation. The concept of the century of humiliation is a special narrative in China. Because during this roughly 100 years, China suffered a lot of foreign invasions and lost wars. And so the Chinese consider this as the darkest period of time in their history.
圆明园和十二生肖青铜兽首是帝国主义侵略的物质提醒。中国政府利用这些兽首进行大规模的政治宣传，试图激起中国人被外国人侮辱的情绪。但像艾未未这样的批评者指出，如果中国政府想要引起人们对中国文化遗产遭到破坏的关注，或许它应该审视一下自己的行为。中国虽然曾遭到帝国主义国家的极力压榨，但中国同样也是其自身政府更大的受害者。仅举一例，在文化大革命期间，
Beginning with the first opium war in 1839 and lasting all the way until the founding of the people's republic in 1949, China was getting absolutely clobbered by foreign forces. It experienced unequal treaties, loss of territory, and multiple wars. And because of the tremendous loss of cultural heritage that took place, a key event in the century of humiliation was the plunder of the UN-MING UN. The UN-MING UN became, to some extent, its assemble of the national humiliation, and so it's being used as a site for the patriotic education. The goal was to make sure younger generations never forgot the lowest period in Chinese history or the destruction of Chinese culture by foreign invaders.
无数的中国文物和文化遗产古迹在共产党的手中遭到毁坏。因此，在艾未未看来，聚焦于青铜兽首的故事感觉像是一种不完整的历史叙述，中国政府在操纵过去，将共产党塑造成受害者，而不是文化破坏行为的施暴者。而这是一种操控人类理解和判断力的艰难方式。这也是最邪恶但也是最高效的方式。
The UN Ming-U-N and the Bronze-Oriac heads were physical reminders of imperialist aggression. Chinese government used this Zugek has in my huge propaganda to try to generate the feeling of a Chinese being insulted by the foreigners. But critics like I Wei Wei have pointed out that if the Chinese government wanted to bring attention to the destruction of Chinese heritage Maybe it should look at its own actions What China has been maximized by the Imperial states But still China is a bigger victim by its own government Just to take one example, during the Cultural Revolution,
在许多方面，这种民族主义策略奏效了。20世纪80年代，中国年轻人走上街头抗议独裁，要求民主。但在90年代、2000年代，他们实际上走上街头抗议外国势力、外国敌对势力。中国现在是一个崛起的全球超级大国，但从一个拍卖行到另一个拍卖行追逐青铜兽首，是一种让这种受害者心态保持活力的方。然而，尽管将人们的注意力吸引到青铜兽首和百年耻辱上对中国政府有利，但并不是只有他们有所收获。
countless amounts of Chinese relics and cultural heritage sites were destroyed at the hands of the Communist Party. So to Iwayway, focusing on the story of the Bronzeheads felt like an incomplete telling of history, that the Chinese government was manipulating the past to frame the Communist Party as the victims victims rather than the perpetrators of culturally destructive practices. And that's a hard way to come and manipulate humans, understanding and judgment. And that is the most evil but also most efficient way.
在2009年伊夫·圣罗兰拍卖会（被蔡铭超恶意破坏而闻名）之后，兔首和鼠首被撤拍。它们最终被佳士得拍卖行的所有者弗朗索瓦·皮诺买下。2013年，皮诺将这些兽首作为两国友谊的象征赠予了中国政府。在皮诺赠送兽首后不久，佳士得成为第一家获得在中国大陆运营执照的国际拍卖行。所以，当然，对这一友谊之举还有其他的解读方式。
In many ways, this nationalistic strategy worked. 1980s, the Chinese young people went to trade to protesting dictatorship, to asking for democracy. But in the 1990s, in 2000s, they actually went to trade protesting the foreign powers, the foreign hostilities. China is now an emerging global superpower, but chasing Bronzeheads from one auction house to another was a way of keeping this sense of victimization alive. But while keeping people's attention towards the Bronzeheads and the century of humiliation has been beneficial for the Chinese government, there are not the only ones who have something
我不想显得愤世嫉俗，你知道的，把它们捐赠回中国，当然是正确的事情。还是弗雷德里克·格林。但随后，当然，你就会发现这其中纠缠着商业、裙带关系和功利主义。如果格林听起来对此感到矛盾，那并不罕见。我为这个故事采访的几乎每个人都希望所有12个青铜兽首最终能回到中国。毕竟，一件被合法掠夺的文物应当归还其原籍国，无论是希腊、埃塞俄比亚还是中国，这都是完全合乎情理的。
to gain. After the 2009 eavesalt Laurent auction that was famously sabotaged by Simon Chao, the rabbit and the rat were withdrawn from sale. They were eventually bought by Francois Pinot, the owner of Christie's auction house. And in 2013, Pinot gifted the heads to the Chinese government as an act of friendship between their two nations. Shortly after Pinot gifted the heads, Christie's became the first international auction house to receive a license to operate on mainland China. So of course, there are other ways to interpret this act of friendship.
但另一方面，许多人不喜欢“做正确的事”本身被劫持用于政治目的的方式。这些青铜兽首背负着既是文化遗产又是政治宣传的不幸重担。但正如帕特里夏·于所说，任何国家宝藏至少都兼而有之。我们在选择如何记住任何特定地点或事件时是非常有选择性的。我的感觉是，没有什么是中立的，我们赋予物品和地点的所有价值，都是被构建的、被协商的、被挑战的。2020年12月，中国国家文物局庆祝了一场重大胜利。为了纪念火烧圆明园的一个重要周年纪念日，青铜马首
I don't want to be cynical, you know, donating them back to China, of course, was, you know, the right thing to do. Frederick Green again. But then, of course, you have this entanglement with business and favoritism and commercialism If green sounds conflicted there, that's not unusual Almost everyone I spoke with for the story wants to see all 12 bronze heads end up back in China After all, it makes perfect sense that a legally stolen relics should be returned back to their country of origin Whether it's Greece, Ethiopia, or China.
在圆明园公园展出。这是自160年前从该遗址被掠夺以来，首件重返故地的十二生肖青铜兽首。现场举行了一场仪式，有大量的演讲和揭幕时刻的倒计时。兴奋的游客挤在一起，拍下玻璃柜内马首的照片。目前还不清楚其他青铜兽首是否最终会加入马首的行列。截至目前，12件已知的青铜兽首中已有7件被找到并归还中国。没有人知道狗首、鸡首、龙首、羊首和蛇首是否还会重现人间。但就目前而言，其中至少有一件——历经耶稣会士、皇帝、伯爵和艺术商人之手
But on the other hand, many people don't like the way the, quote, right thing to do has itself been commandeered for political purposes. The Bronzeheads have the unfortunate burden of being both cultural heritage and propaganda. But as Patricia Yu says, any national treasure is at least a little bit of both. We're quite selective about how we choose to remember any particular place or event. I just come from the sense that nothing is neutral, that all of the values that we put upon objects and sites, they are constructed, they are negotiated, they are challenged. In December of 2020, the State Administration of Cultural Heritage in China celebrated a big victory. To mark an important anniversary of the sacking of the Palace complex, the bronze horse
终于回到了家。维维安将在中场休息后回来向我讲述一些可能是一堆非常有趣的巧合。所以我又和维维安·莱特在一起了，嗨，维维。嗨，罗曼。所以当我们录制时，我们正在2月12日农历新年这天互相交谈，所以新年快乐。新年快乐，是的。
hat went on display at the UN Ming-U-N Park. It was the first Zodiac bronze to return to the grounds since they were eluded from the site 160 years ago. There was a ceremony with lots of speeches and a countdown to a big unveiling moment. Excited tourists crowded around to snap a picture of the horse inside of its glass case. It's unclear whether the other bronzes will eventually join the horse on the grounds. As of now, seven of the twelve known bronzads have been located and returned back to China. No one knows if the dog, rooster, dragon, sheep, and snake will ever turn up. But for now, at least one of them them having passed through the hands of Jesuits, emperors, eurols, and art dealers
我想我为你准备了一个带有生肖主题的尾声，这是受艾未未的启发。太棒了。所以，这个故事充满了许多奇怪的巧合。比如，我们从未真正打算在农历新年左右发布这一集，这只是碰巧发生了，因为我为此工作了一年。不。而且恰好赶上了农历新年，这挺酷的。是的。
had finally come home. Vivian will come back to tell me about what is probably a bunch of really interesting coincidences after the break. So I'm back with Vivian Light, Hey Viv. Hey Roman. So as we are recording, we're talking to each other on February 12th, Lunar New Year, so happy New Year. Happy New Year, yeah.
但同时，当我采访艾未未时，他指出了另一个巧合，那就是我们是在2021年2月交谈的，这几乎正好是2009年2月伊夫·圣罗兰拍卖会之后的12年，而那场拍卖会正是艾未未的圆阵艺术品以及本文的灵感来源。今年是一个完整的循环，12年。所以对中国人来说，这很有意义。而且对这次采访来说，恰好用了12年也是一种巧合。
I guess I have kind of a zodiac theme, Coda for you, which was inspired by Ai Weiwei. Great. So, this story has been filled with a lot of like odd coincidences. Like, we never really intended this episode to release, you know, around Lunar New Year, just kind of happened because I've been working on this for like a year. No. And just happened to fall on Lunar New Year, which was kind of cool. Yeah.
所以，我们在生肖周期的圆满完成时聊到这个主题，真有点像命中注定。那么你所说的生肖周期是什么意思？是的，我们在主线故事中稍微讨论过这一点，中国十二生肖有12种动物，每种动物都按特定顺序排列，并对应不同的农历年份。而动物的顺序实际上来自一个古老的民间传说，叫做
But also, when I was interviewing Ai Weiway, he pointed out another coincidence, which was that we were talking to each other in February of 2021, which was almost exactly 12 years after the Eve's son, Laurent Auction, which took place in February of 2009, which was the inspiration for both Iwayway's circle of animals are a piece and also for this piece. This year is complete circle, 12 years. So for Chinese, it's quite meaningful. But also for this interview, it's kind of coincident that it took exactly 12 years.
大赛。关于这个故事有很多变体，但基本上就是生肖动物互相赛跑，以争取成为玉皇大帝历法的一部分。它们完成比赛的顺序就是它们在历法中出现的顺序。所以十二生肖按顺序是鼠、牛、虎、兔、龙、蛇、马、羊、
So it was kind of like, kismet that we were chatting about this subject at the completion of a zodiac cycle. And so what do you mean by the zodiac cycle? Yeah, so we kind of covered this a little bit in the main story, but there are 12 animals of the Chinese zodiac, and each of the animals fall in a specific order and correspond to a different lunar year. And the order of the animals actually comes a specific order and correspond to a different lunar year. And the order of the animals actually comes from this ancient folklore called
猴、鸡、狗，最后一名是猪。因此，截至2021年2月12日，我们告别了鼠年，迎来了牛年。这可不是赛跑时的顺序。我想象它们在比赛中应该是那样的。关于这个完整的故事，其实还有很多抓马。我想我没有时间解释整个过程，但老鼠是一种狡猾的动物。
the Great Race. And there's a lot of variations to this story, but basically the animals of the zodiac raced against each other to be part of the Jade Emperor's calendar. And the order that they finish the race is the order that they appear in the calendar. So the zodiac animals in order are the rat, ox, tiger, rabbit, dragon, snake, horse, goat,
原来如此。所以我们正处于牛年。所以我们结束了鼠年，我们正处于牛年。听起来是个好兆头。这是一个踏实的好年份。所以我认为我们正处于牛年。所以听起来是件好事。这是一个踏实的年份。是的，这是一个踏实的年份。所以我知道我们会没事的。但艾未未在采访中提到的一件事真正印在了我的脑海里，因为这是我内心深处一直有的一种感觉。
monkey, rooster, dog, and then in last place was the pig. So as of February 12th, 2021, we left behind the year of the rat and have entered the year of the ox. That is not the order. I would think that they would place an erase. There's a lot of drama actually that's more related to this whole story. I don't think I have the time to explain the entire thing, but the rat is a crafty animal.
我当时并没有意识到这是一个广为人知的迷信。但你知道大家是怎么责怪2020年太糟糕的，因为发生了太多可怕的事情。是的。我的意思是，这一整年发生了无数可怕的事情，人们对2020年都非常愤怒，并希望2021年会更好，但作为开端它稍微有点摇晃。是的，我们有了一条鱼，并开启了新年，但艾未未说，这实际上
I see. So we're in the year of the ox. So we finished the rat, we're in the year of the ox. That sounds like a good thing. It's a good solid year. So I think we're in the year of the ox. So that sounds like a good thing. It's a good solid. Yeah, it's a solid year. So I know we're going to be okay. But there was one thing that I way, way mentioned in our interview that really stuck with me because this is something that I had been feeling deep down in my gut.
可能是因为鼠年或老鼠年。中国人总是相信鼠年会带来巨大的灾难。历史上的怪事也证明了这一点。所以艾未未说，我们应该忽略公历年份2020年，而将农历新年即鼠年视为过去一年我们所有动荡的根源。是的，我在我们交谈后立即查了查，这实际上是一个有据可查的诡异现象，即每当逢鼠年时，中国总会发生一些悲惨的事情，
And I didn't realize that this was a known superstition. But you know how everyone was blaming 2020 for sucking because so many terrible things happen. Yeah. I mean, there were numerous horrible things that happened throughout the year and people were all very mad at 2020 and we're hoping that 2021 would be better, but it's a little shaky as a bit. Yeah, we had a fish and he starts the new year, but I way away said that it may have
但特别是在金鼠年期间。那么什么是金鼠年？所以我将在刚才向你解释的农历上再增加一层。所以每12年的生肖周期都属于五行之一。即金、木、水、火、土。所以金鼠年，也就是我们刚刚度过的公历2020年所在的年份，实际上每60年才发生一次。
actually been because of the year of the rat or the year of the mouse. Chinese always believe the year of mouse would always have a huge disaster. And it's been proved and the strange people cut in history. So Iwayway says that we should be ignoring the Gregorian calendar, the year 2020, and focus on the lunar new year, the year the rat, as the source of all of our turmoil over the past year. Yes, and I immediately look this up like after we spoke, and it's actually a documented eerie phenomenon that something tragic always happens to China in the year that coincides with the rat,
所以告诉我为什么人们认为金鼠年是被诅咒的，如果我们追溯每60年，有哪些灾害？是的，如果你一直追溯到1840年的金鼠年，中国刚刚陷入第一次鸦片战争，这场战争以大量人员伤亡、领土丧失告终，但也是百年耻辱的开端。所以一开始，1840年，就不是个好年份。不是个好年份。好吧，我们在节目中已经证明了这一点。好的。然后，你把时间快进另一个60年到1900年。中国正处于处理义和团运动的过程中。
but specifically during the year of the metal rat. So what's a metal rat? So I'm gonna add one more layer to the lunar calendar that I just explained to you. So every 12-year zodiac cycle falls under one of five different elements. So there's wood, fire, earth, metal, and water. So the year of the metal rat, which is the year that we actually just went through with
但具体是在金鼠年。那么什么是金鼠年呢？我将在刚刚向你们解释的农历基础上再增加一个层面。每12年的生肖周期都属于五行之一，即木、火、土、金、水。所以金鼠年——也就是我们刚刚经历的
the 2020 Gregorian calendar year, that actually only happens once every 60 years. So tell me why people think that the year of the metal rat is cursed, like what are some of the disasters if we go back every 60 years? Yeah, so if you go all the way back to the year of the metal rat in 1840 China had just gotten into the first opium war, which ended with a lot of loss of life, loss of territory, but was also the kickoff to the century of humiliation. So right up the gate, 1840, not a good year. Not a good year. Okay, we've demonstrated that in the piece. Okay. And so, you fast forward another 60 years to the year 1900. China is in the middle of dealing with a boxer rebellion.
2020年公历年——其实每60年才发生一次。那么请告诉我，为什么人们认为金鼠年是被诅咒的呢？如果我们每隔60年回溯一次，会有哪些灾难？是的，如果你一直追溯到1840年的金鼠年，中国刚刚陷入第一次鸦片战争，这场战争以大量人员伤亡和领土丧失告终，这也是百年屈辱史的开端。所以一开局，1840年就不是个好年份。确实不是个好年份。好吧，我们在文章中已经证明了这一点。好吧。然后，你再把时间快进60年到1900年。中国正处于应对义和团运动的时期。
And it's believed that like up to 100,000 people possibly died during this conflict. And it pretty much ended the Qing dynasty. So that's another like tremendous loss of life during the middle rat. And then if you jump another 60 years to the year 1960, China was in the middle of the worst famine brought on by the Great Leap Forward. And it's actually considered the deadliest famine in human history.
据信在这场冲突中有高达十万人可能丧生，这基本上终结了清朝。所以这也是金鼠年期间又一次巨大的生命损失。然后如果你再往后推60年，到1960年，中国正处于“大跃进”引发的最严重饥荒之中，这实际上被认为是人类历史上最致命的饥荒。
Wow. Wow. And so if you go 60 years after that, it's 20 joining. You were in the middle of a global pandemic that China particularly hard. Yeah. Yeah. it's spooky. Yeah, I mean, that's definitely a spooky coincidence. I mean, I guess you could either believe that the year of the metal rat is cursed, you know, and that, you know, maybe we have 60 more years to prepare for the next disaster,
哇。哇。所以如果你从那以后再过60年，就是2020年。你正处于一场对中国打击特别沉重的全球大流行病之中。是的。是的。这很诡异。是的，我的意思是，这绝对是一个诡异的巧合。我的意思是，我想你既可以相信金鼠年是被诅咒的，你知道，也许我们还有60年的时间来为下一场灾难做准备，
or you can believe that the world is filled with coincidences and that terrible things. You know, happen all the time. I'm you can believe that the world is filled with coincidences and that terrible things don't happen all the time. I'm pretty inclined to believe the latter. I wonder if you picked any other year and gave it some periodicity if you would find horrible things happening throughout. But it's fascinating that, you know, like he grabbed onto that and then you got inspired by it. And I learned a little bit about the zodiac calendar.
或者你可以相信世界上充满了巧合，可怕的事情，你知道，一直在发生。我倾向于相信后者。我在想，如果你随便挑出另一个年份并赋予它某种周期性，你是否也会发现可怕的事情不断发生。但令人着迷的是，你知道，他抓住了这一点，然后你受到了启发。我也对生肖历有了点了解。
So that's cool. Yeah, totally. But yeah, whether you believe the curse of the Melorat or not, happy year of the ox, Roman. Yeah, happy year of the ox. A very special thanks this week to Alice in Claimment and Tidal Corn, and also thanks to Wishouli and Greg Thomas, whose interviews did not make it into this episode. If you want to read more about the century of humiliation
所以这很酷。是的，完全同意。不过话说回来，无论你是否相信金鼠年的诅咒，祝你牛年快乐，罗曼。是的，牛年快乐。本周要特别感谢爱丽丝·克莱门特和蒂代尔·科恩，还要感谢吴秀莉和格雷格·托马斯，他们的采访未能进入本集节目。如果你想了解更多关于百年耻辱
and patriotic education, make sure to check out Zhang Wang's book, Never Forget National Humiliation. And if you'd like to learn more about Iwayway's circle of animal zodiac heads, you can visit zodiacheads.com. 99% of visible was produced this week by Vivian Le. Mixed by Bryson Barnes, music by John Rial, translation and production assistance for this episode was provided by Wen Ji Yang. Our senior producers to Laney Hall, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, the way it's a
和爱国主义教育的信息，请务必阅读王争的书《永不忘记国耻》。如果你想了解更多关于艾未未的十二生肖兽首圈子的信息，你可以访问zodiacheads.com。本周的《99%无形》由维维安·勒制作，布赖森·巴恩斯混音，约翰·里亚尔配乐，本集节目的翻译和制作协助由温济阳提供。我们的高级制作人是莱尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，团队成员
team is Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Baroube, Joe Rosenberg, Katie Mangle, Abby Madon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K, LW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered like zodiac heads around the world, but will someday come home to beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
有克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯·巴鲁贝、乔·罗森伯格、凯蒂·曼格、艾比·马顿、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7K LW的项目，制作于“无线电街”，它像生肖兽首一样散落在世界各地，但总有一天会回到美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下Radiotopia的创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、听众支持、100%艺术家拥有的播客组成的激烈独立的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99pi org, or on Instagram and Reddit too. But for pictures and more about this story, go to 99pi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，或@节目 99pi org，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上找到我们。但有关这个故事的图片和更多信息，请访问 99pi.org。来自PRX。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。